[Music
] My name is aristiderontini I'm a
performer and choreographer in Italy with
disabilities
[Music]
as a choreographer and artist I'm very
intrigued by how a show can
influence the audience's perception
on a topic that is being investigated at that
moment I think the  dance
is certainly an instrument of pleasure
and of sharing a
bodily experience but I also think it has the
ability to shake things up and therefore
definitions and words and therefore give
complexity and fluidity to very
rigid definitions and with very rigid outlines.
Therefore to this power  to fluidify and
connect my working method which is not
yet well defined But I see
that when there is a need with respect to a
theme I like it I feel the need to have
to feed this theme broaden
it understand it understand it from several points of
view  and it is purely a work of
comparison with people or of reading
and therefore of searching for information that
helps me understand how that  the thing
is seen and how I look at it how
to be able to present it again in another
guise so there is all a
fairly conceptual work of
theoretical research and then afterwards there is the moment of the
room and the meeting and which
narrows the field  possibilities
in meeting performers
lately I must say in recent
projects I have always left more room for
performers to connect even
individually with respect to the theme by proposing
very simple practices that give
freedom and gradually tightening
the last project I completed  they are
called litakumi and staves relationship
between man and nature
how ideas also
shape our actions and
direct our relationship with
nature what I really liked about
this show
in the creation was the work with
video projections dancing objects and
throwing us  in this to have created a
scenario where the performers were able to
experiment playing by connecting with the
theme and see that c  osa came out in
a very short time which was also
quite stressful but which in the
end almost at an institutional level brought
out solutions both from the perspective
of the dancers and from my perspective
in which I recognized myself a lot so
this Alla  In the end I must say it was a
project that really excited me
[Applause]
[Music]
for me the thing that most intrigues me
about this work is really starting from
something very familiar and starting to
touch the edges of the unknown and then
seeing how these two polarities
meet in the show is always a
discovery that sometimes destabilizes
me sometimes makes me contract totally
unexpected things So I believe that even
when I watch a show I create it I
am inside a creation as a performer
I think this is the aspect  more
nourishing in our work
[Music]